hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice miniature that was played in 1981
in the Mexico City World Junior Chess
Championship displayed between oguns
Witten with the white pieces and Nigel
short and okay I couldn't find a photo
of omean sweet'n when he was younger but
I do have a couple of photos here I have
one from 1992 and where he is where he
is definitely younger and I do have one
from 1979 so he's the guy on the far
left so two years even before this game
was played but it's of really poor
quality so I decided to use this one as
it's much nicer even though he's older
in this photo but regardless now about
the the match yesterday it was it was a
very nice game and after that first goal
that England scored that was a there was
a monster goal when I saw that free-kick
I was like that is that is very
impressive and then Croatia managed to
equalize which I have no idea how that
ball connected with his foot it was like
parish you know kicked the ball with his
toe but regardless you know it's it was
an equaliser and then Manju Kitsch went
for four to one and then Croatia was
able to keep the score all the way to
the end and I read somewhere that Manju
Kitsch spent like four thousand dollars
to buy to buy beers for for for Croatian
fans in Russia and that is a lot of beer
but yeah creational qualified for the
finals of the World Cup and it seems
fitting that you know if you want to
become world champion you have to you
have to be able to overcome the French
defense so we'll talk about that a bit
more on Sunday but now let's get back to
this game so it's open and sweetened
with the white pieces against Nigel
short we have d4 Knight to f6 c4 e6
and Knight to f3 so avoiding the
nimzo-indian would Knight to c3 so
basically this is the antonyms oh just
just a second so Knight to f3 b6 and now
a3 this is the petrosyan variation of
the Queen's Indian defense not not
allowing something like Knight to c3
were black and
even transpose back into the queen's
indian defense i worship to be four and
then here black is basically the one
that that chooses what to play here it's
wheaton goes for a three we have see
five now and now d5 further expanding in
the center grabbing more space to a six
attacking the c4 pawn and sweeten
defense that would Queen to c2
we have pawn captures pawn captures and
now Russia back to b7 this is a standard
idea in the Queen's Indian defense why
you might ask yourself why not keep the
bishop here you know it seems like this
is a very nice pin if whatever moves the
the pond and you can capture on f1 well
even if you do something like this let's
see let's say just keep on developing
what will gladly go E for and after you
capture okay King f1 you did mess up his
castling privileges about after black
continues developing simply g3 king g2
is coming the rook is coming into the
game White has a very nice Center and
all is well here so nothing really
nothing really for black here you know
you only mess up White's castling
privileges for for a bit and then white
will be able to cast artificially
anyways so let's go back to b7 we have E
for now Queen to e7 attacking the e4
pawn twice but also now d4 d4 pawn is
pinned the Knight captures on d5 is a
threat threat so here we have a very
nice pawn sacrifice by sweeten Bishop to
d3 and okay Knight captures on d5
sweeten castles now the knight is under
attack as the pawn is no longer pinned
and now the e3 pawn really comes in very
handy as now nice to be four is
impossible we have Knight back to c7 and
Knight to c3 it's okay for the price of
one pawn as we can really get a lot of
development and Nigel really has to
figure out how to go from here Queen
back to d8 you don't want to allow
Knight to d5 with an attack on the Queen
and of course black never wants to
capture on d5 and allow each after some
d5 to be able so white will be able to
play rook e1 and open up this Queen
Bishop battery so Queen back to d8 and
now comes Knight to d5 we have nine
three six avoiding the exchange
and here Nigel is still up upon and if
he will be able to defend okay then
maybe he will be able to counter White's
initiative and here you could definitely
go for some development rookie one maybe
be three prepare Bush or b2 but here
it's Wheaton goes nice to e5 which is
basically looking for adventure
we have Knight to c6 and now comes f4
Knight captures on e5 f captures on e5
and Bishop to e7 Queen to e2 and here
Nigel really has to figure out what to
do so the basic question is can black
castle here well he can but it's it's
not all that easy to make this decision
if you Castle here then white
immediately jumps in with Queen to h5
then Knight to f6 is a big threat so if
you decide to play something like Bishop
captures on d5 then comes pawn captures
immediately you freed the bishop Queen
captures on h7 is a big threat after g6
Queen moves and now you do have to do
something about your night here and
there is really not all that much you
can do if you move the knight then d6
comes you're losing the bishop on e7
after better beige for ng3 the bishop is
trapped and white wins the game here and
on the other hand after a Queen to h5 if
you don't capture the night here if you
try something like let's say King h8
then comes Knight to f6 never you know
regardless captures captures attacking
the bishop and here it's again not all
that clear what the black can do here to
defend if you capture them he 5 wins the
game immediately as Queen captures on h7
is a threat and there's really no good
way to prevent to this like no way
whatsoever even if you block with the
night but rook captures night is coming
so this is only prolonging the
inevitable
so although it is possible to castle
here and the defender but you know in a
practical game it's very unlikely that
black would actually castle here so here
Nigel short goes for h6 310 immediately
jumps in Queen to h5 and the now comes
Luke to a faith so okay Nigel decided he
will not be castling kingside this game
he has to protect the f7 pawn and here
okay there are a lot of possible ideas
here but sweeten goes for the most act
one mushroom captures on h6 not really
interested in that porn what's weaken is
interested in is connecting rooks as
soon as possible getting that Bishop out
of the way and then rook captures on f7
is a threat and then the other rook can
come and assume this F 1 square instead
of this rook so this is the plan and
black really doesn't have all that much
choice black has to capture the bishop G
captures on h h6 was played and now
comes rope captures on f7 you have to
capture the rook or else you're getting
checkmate it after a simple discoveries
made solo captures and now comes the
rook to f1 so this is the idea attacking
the pin piece rook on f7 is attack Queen
captures on f7 is the threat of
checkmate Knight to g5 the knight is
defending the rock Anderson this is the
only good move and the only move that
allows the black to keep on defending
here Bishop to c4 introducing another
attacker as the bishop and III isn't
doing all that much Bishop to c4
introducing another attacker into into
this story and here it's a very
unpleasant position for black definitely
but black can yet to defend so here I
want you to pause the video here and try
to find a way black could have defended
this position so I will give it a couple
of seconds if you want to give it a shot
for those of you who were able to do it
if you found a bunch of captures on d5
that's that's that's alright but there
is an even better move that is Queen to
b8 if you found Queen to b8 then you are
definitely an excellent defender and I
congratulate you because now the idea is
after Queen cab after rook captures and
Knight captures in this knight to f6
check now opening up a double attack
from the Queen and the bishop King to d8
and now Queen captures on f7 and now
black has a choice either you found
Bishop captures which leads to a force
draw after a repetition of moves here or
you have found after Queen captures on
f7 this Bishop to c6 move but that's not
all that easy to do give up yet another
piece after Queen checks King moves you
captured a bishop but then Queen to f8
comes and after you move the Queen black
introduces his rook into the game and
now black is up the exchange and is able
to play this game
but you know it's not an easy move to
find Queen to be a to Nigel didn't find
it and he didn't play upon better
captures rather he played King to a fate
he decided I'm gonna unpin so now white
is forced to capture but he missed one
move bytes written so here pause the
video and find the attacking idea that
that nigel missed in this position I
will give it a couple of seconds if you
wanna you know give it a shot for those
of you who were able to do it I can
gradually do you an excellent attacker
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show its hidden played rope captures on
f7 Knight captures on f7 and here the
move you had to find Knight to f6 Knight
to f6
after nigel saw this he resigned the
game and a great victory for for the
creation player open and sweeten what if
he resigned well of course Queen
captures on f7 is the threat of
checkmate there's no real good way to
defend the night oh you can give up some
material but that's only saving you
temporarily you know prolonging the
inevitable even Queen the Queen Queen e8
giving up the Queen as the knight is
guarding here so there's really nothing
to do here you could try something like
nice to h8 but then again okay
not the Knight is guarding f7 button now
clean captures on h6 is checkmate as the
bishop is slicing all the way here and
the night is gonna yet as we said and
try something like d5 again only
prolonging the inevitable
simply pawn captures on poisson and
again the idea is completely the same so
after this Knight to f6 move Nigel
resigned the game and a very nice
victory for all units Wheaton who in
1981 won the World Junior Chess
Championship in Mexico City
so yeah Croatia will also have a chance
on Sunday to become World Cup winners
but in order to do that they will have
to overcome the French defense so that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it I
would like to thank Christian stork
Allan Asbury Danny McCullough Doug
Alberto Gonzales and the Matthew
Sperling for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous video serie thank you for
watching and I will see you soon with
another interesting video thank you